this is a production of Cornell
University hello everyone my name is
keny Rodriguez I am a PhD student at
Cornell University and I am here with
Steve reers he's a Horticulture
specialist and today we'll talk about
harvesting zucchini so Steve sometimes
people grow their vegetables but they
don't know how to harvest or when is the
right time to harvest so can you explain
us a little bit when is the right time
to harvest zucchini sure um yeah with
zucchini it's a little bit maybe a
little difficult for the beginner
because it doesn't turn color like a
tomato wood that would let you know when
to harvest zucchini it just gets too big
and we've got an example of that right
here um today which is zucchini which
probably should have been harvested last
week and you can see the size of this
one here now I've got I've got gloves on
and normally I'd even be wearing long
sleeves because zucchini squash has
these little
um tricomes that can actually be pretty
sharp and can give you small little
scratches there so it's something to be
aware of um when you're doing this so
I'm going to use my clippers here now
you could just go out there and just
sort of twist it and I've done that but
sometimes when you do that you actually
hurt the plant if you're just twisting
it like that so this is one that
certainly is too large and we'll going
to cut this one open later and show you
why that's a problem um I remember years
ago I had a home Gardener bring me one
that was probably twice the size and he
was just so proud of it and he thought
that I as a horiculture professor would
want that and I gratefully took it from
him and as soon as he left I just threw
it in the garbage because zucchinis will
get this big and the problem is not only
are they are they bad eating but a lot
of resources from the plant all the
photosynthates that go into this and
you're not going to use it so it's a
drain on the plant so that's why we
don't want to we don't want to get one
this big here this is just a perfect
size of the zucchini it's still you
could get them smaller if you wanted to
but this is a really nice one it's about
would you say maybe 5 in in length now
again I'm going to just use use my
clippers here to get this one um so I
don't do any damage to the plant you can
see just how nice that is compared to
that other
one so Steve just showed us uh when is
the right time to harvest the zucchini
and now we're going to cut the zucchini
to see how it looks small one in this
huge one that we just collected and
Kenzie this is the same variety right
yes so yeah how they just get big yeah
okay
so you can see this one I'm going to put
it right there the seeds are still small
the the texture is going to be good this
one I almost need an axe to get in to
this one
here so imagine if you're in the kitchen
trying to cut this now people will use
this sometimes to make zucchini bread
but it's not something that you'd want
to use I think just in the in the
kitchen as you would with the smaller
zucchini
yeah look at that here you can just see
all the seeds that we've got and this is
almost like a cottony material it's
going to be very bad eating but look at
the size of those seeds as compared to
the seeds that you've got in this one so
this would not be very good eating at
all so we just learned how to harvest
zucchini and you can see here the
difference between the two zucchinis and
we now learn that it's better to have
like smaller size because this seed will
be smaller and it will be better for um
eating it so now whenever you're going
to grow your chinis you know when it's
the right time to harvest this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at cornell.edu